hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein ganz kurzes rezept ich
werde nämlich ein getränk machen und
zwar habe ich hier einen 40 ice t
zubereitet den haben wir auf unserer
usa-reise sehr oft getrunken
eigentlich fast jeden tag den gab es
wirklich überall immer selbstgemachten
riesen kanistern und jetzt habe ich
gedacht kombi zu haben wir das selber
mal nach eisleben stets zu fast 80
prozent immer aus schwarztee weil
einfach spaß die sehr aromatisch ist und
ich habe hier in meinem eistee schwarz
die mit drin und pfirsich und zitrone
und im prinzip braucht ihr wirklich nur
diese drei zutaten um ein leckeres
erfrischendes getränk zauber man kann
auch natürlich auch für meine party
macht abend und windows oder nicht kann
man super vorbereiten grüßen am besten
in einem ganz großen kanister hier habe
ich jetzt zitroneneis täterin 40 und da
hat man wirklich ein gerechteres
blausternchen behält ja und jedenfalls
ist wirklich sehr lecker und erfrischend
und ich zeige euch jetzt mal wie ich den
10 hergestellt habe solange ein oder
lang für den fc braucht jetzt nur ganz
wenige zutaten und zwar habe ich hier
vorne drei esslöffeln schwarztee da wir
jetzt einen ceylan teilgenommen 240 etwa
500 gramm eine zitrone und dann
hochwasser das wasser habe ich jetzt
bereits schon aufkochen lassen und jetzt
den herd ausgestellt also halt so etwa
95 grad und es ist auch die perfekte
temperatur um schwarzen tee damit zu
überbringen
beim schwarzen tee geht natürlich
verschiedene sorten wir haben eben eben
diesen wir haben eben immer diesen jamie
t zu hause weil wir gegen ganz gerne
trinken da schmeckt wirklich sehr würzig
und aromatisch und er eignet sich eben
super weil er eben sehr
geschmacksintensiv ist gebt ihr die
teeblätter einfach in so eine große glas
charakter oder eine teekanne zum
beispiel und überbrüht den teams mit
etwa 600 milliliter heißem wasser
den lasse ich jetzt hier einfach für
etwa drei bis fünf minuten stehen das
erzählen kann und kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die pfirsiche
nehmen und die viertel
und die 40 viertel gebe ich jetzt hier
in einem kleinen topf
und da kommen jetzt so etwa 400
milliliter wasser mit dazu und dann
lasse ich das ganze so etwa vier bis
fünf minuten aufkochen
jetzt dürften die fertig stücke lange
genug kochen jetzt nämlich noch die
zitrone und presst den saft aus und zwar
kommt das jetzt einfach mit zum tee und
dann macht den meister auch so richtig
frisch
ich hab mir übrigens einfach eine bio
zitrone die einfach noch ein bisschen
grün ist statt gelb jetzt kann ich das
komplette rad einmal zusammen stellen
ich nehme an sie und gesten und er
sollte auch gar nicht viel zu lange
ziehen da er ansonsten bitter wird oder
bitter werden kann
die teekanne spiele ich jetzt kurz aus
handy benutze ich jetzt weiter
und jetzt kommen darauf die pferd durch
schüsse mit rein und die streiche jetzt
auch durch den sieg durch die haut kann
man dann einfach abziehen und wegnehmen
und hier kommen jetzt natürlich auch die
ganze 40 flüssigkeit mit reihenweise da
ganze geschmack mit drin
und wer möchte kann natürlich auch an
dieser stelle den tc süßen mit zucker
mich dass es jetzt weg weil mir einfach
die frucht süße aus den vierzigern schon
reicht aber falls es süß dann jetzt an
der stelle weil ist der tenor heiß ist
und dass ich dann auch eben gut auflöst
jetzt kann diese t konzentrat erstmal
abkühlen ich las es jetzt erstmal auf
zimmertemperatur kommen und stellt dann
in den kühlschrank und dann zeige ich
euch wieder 14 serviert wird das ice t
konzentrat ist schön kalt
und jetzt kann uns natürlich so lassen
aber so sieht natürlich sehr trüb aus
wobei eben das so einfach sei natürlich
ist durch den 40 aber wenn ihr möchtet
könnt es auch einmal durch sein
durch den filter geben ein kaffeefilter
als ideal jetzt habe ich keine ich habe
einen filter da ihr könnt auch eine
telefonnummer
reine baumwolle natürlich frisch sein
neben geschmack geben
das ok und altes t-shirt
hmm
und jetzt gebe ich da noch ein paar wer
sich stücke mit rein und ein paar
zitronenscheiben bei stiftung warentest
letzte woche besteck getestet messe
haben am besten abgeschnitten
mächtig
die gebe ich jetzt sie mit rein und ein
paar zitronenscheiben also das ist eine
zitrone aber sieht alt aus wenn mir die
gegeben ich kann nicht die ganze grüne
zitrone zitrone nicht wundern dass wir
zwar leicht grün ist richtig gut
ich glaube die lachen sich geht alles
schief die gebe ich jetzt hier auch noch
mit rein und dann darfst du jetzt
probieren
man muss jetzt halt dazu sagen also
erwartungshaltung darf jetzt nicht darf
jetzt nicht so hoch sein denn eins steht
er schon fertig aus der flasche ist oder
aus der verpackung dörfler und genau das
ist süß und daher kommt eben der
geschmack also als wie in den usa auch
selbstgemachte getrunken haben
ich glaube du hast mach gesüßt ich habe
ihn so getrunken weil es ist einfach
schwarze und eben ein bisschen für sich
mit dabei und da kann er nicht so viel
geschmack kommen nicht so viel süßes
aber er ist auch länger einwirken
ja aber sozusagen es ist halt gesund
nicht so ungesund wie ein normaler eis
sehen
man kann ihr nach süßen in amerika als
aber global
da hat es überall gegeben da haben die
leute wirklich überall in den einzigen
toten in allen restaurants und hätte nur
noch nicht enthalten halt jetzt strecken
wir den geschmack noch mit einem fall
verhalten jetzt kriegst du dann noch ein
bisschen hübsch aber das auge isst ja
auch mit sowie zeit normal aber ist
menge einwirken ich mach dir noch der
deckel nämlich gleich auch die terrasse
damit perfekt also zum wollten
er schnitt fiel besser aus als der aus
chicago er hat ja auch noch nichts
geschmeckt und nach klar das wasser so
klar hat es ja weil es mir spaß tisch
mit jetzt so richtig schön für sich
das ist jetzt so nicht halten ganz
ehrlich wer jetzt gedacht da ich nicht
so süß aber jedem für sich du hast aber
glaub schon lange einwirken lassen
ich hab's der eier gekocht und dann
eindecken müssen aber echt zu elf
stunden ist gut aber ohne sport und
falls er mal nur zitroneneis tee machen
wollt könnt ihr das machen so wie hier
bei mir nach der ice-t sehr klar dann
nimmt die anderen schwarztee und könnte
die zitronen so ein bisschen auspressen
die scheiben mit dazu und dann hab jetzt
rohner ist ohne spaß also ist beweist
ein bisschen wissen wirklich ein super
aussehen wird ja dann braucht ihr mimik
süßen also echt süß genug dms ich also
die trolle oder nicht wir wissen es
nicht vertrauen
also es stimmt also dieses rezept auch
nach machen wollt geht ob sie ließ ihn
nicht los dass stets nur mal für euch
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachmachen und bis zum nächsten mal
einmal wie sagen die amerikaner